[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life
for a long time i'm link and i'm right
this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're gonna be
catching up with each other hey about
our spring breaks
we did spring break man you're still red
you're still link
yep i still am man um
yeah our our breaks kind of
you know they they weren't this was the
first year i think that they weren't at
the same time
yeah because uh our kids go to different
school
systems even though what is school you
know with all of this
trying to come out of the covet of it
all i don't know
but spring break doesn't mean what
spring break
used to mean because school nothing
means what it uses but it does mean they
don't have to be on
zoom calls all day well it means that
yeah
there isn't the only thing spring break
still means there is no school for that
week it's just that our kids it's two
different weeks so like
uh mine was a three weeks back now and
yours was last week
so it's basically just like mine's not
as fresh
but i'll tell you a big thing did happen
in terms of an update and it's
and it is kind of tied to the season of
spring break and that is
a huge milestone in the neil home
uh fourth child christy is pregnant
no god listen let's see how long we can
let that sit out there oh i already said
no
i'm sorry you mean oh no i don't know we
don't know if we're going to give it up
no i don't
no it's not true
okay no quite the opposite in
the neil home we gained an adult
our oldest child lily freaking turned
18 years old so now that he's like out
number of the children even as i'm
saying
it i don't believe it well in my house
i'm not considered an adult
but right okay uh and that is the
running jokes and now there
are christie has another adult there's
two moms and three boys
so i i wanna i want to talk about
that because i need to process that
um but but let's start with uh
let's start with the vacation since it's
very fresh i don't know if there's
you know if there's something to kick it
off here and then we'll certainly get
back to you
i saw something the adult in my home you
saw i saw something
on my on my spring break now uh we went
to the beach
and uh we stayed in a
like a a community of condos
kind of on the beach right and uh
what i noticed pretty early about this
community of condos
is that while there were other people
doing what i was doing which is like
you know renting it for a week there was
a lot of people who had chosen to retire
to this community side note i was like
that seems nice you know i'm like
i'm sitting there uh washing off my
surfboards on the
on the like the little porch area and
this
british woman in a robe with a newspaper
in one hand and a cup of coffee in the
other hand
that's the life isn't it just walks out
and she says hello
and i'm just like mary poppins is here
oh gosh and
and she she was just she had an umbrella
well she if she had a third hand she
would you don't need an umbrella in
southern california man
well when i went to the beach a couple
weeks ago it what it did rain well your
first two days you picked the wrong week
we got no rain it was beautiful the
whole time
yeah and she was mary poppins on my trip
she i was you know cleaning my surfboard
and she was like oh um
i thought they might be cleaning like
there's people who come in clean or
whatever
and i was like nope just me washing my
surfboard and she was like i'm margaret
she kept it going hello margaret
yeah i and she just seemed
and later i saw her like walking with
her husband and they just seemed so
happy and contented
it's because you don't know them well
well i mean i don't know i mean they're
human
i can be that old with a robe it's hard
to be happy and contented man
especially i'm actually concerned for
her it's like she lives in this condo
permanently but then she's got
these people who just come in and out of
the place every week she likes
she's like strangers though i wouldn't
like that part of it but she does
you can tell that's why she did tell her
your name did you get into a
conversation
she was like i'm margaret i'm like oh
i'm just rhett
margaret actually i didn't say that now
that i think about it i should have said
that
would you like a cigarette she looked
like she might have been a smoker but
um what do you mean by that nothing and
then
are her lips they she just looks
sometimes i feel like i like it i can
look at the lips of people who i think
are smokers and because growing up i do
know there is a certain
um wrinkly lip associated with the
pooching of the lips for
smoking cigarettes i wasn't talking
about sad smoker i was talking about
cool smoker
there's a difference well that shouldn't
be talked about at all i know we
shouldn't do anything that's not
cool if i said marlborough man we went
we've been through that generation
i'm not trying to bring it back i'm just
saying i believe that margaret might
have been a part of the marlboro man
generation like a cool cool smoker
anyway she just had that vibe and her
voice was a little raspy but
that's not even what i wanted to talk
about because i saw another woman
speaking of contented good lord um
i'm walking with the boys uh so there's
like one
uh it's one of those you know up and
down the southern california coast
for a large portion of the california
coast there are these bluffs
yes you know what i'm saying it's not
like north carolina where it's just like
you kind of go over some sand dunes and
there's just beach
and what in california you got bluffs so
basically these
dirt cliffs and so the beach accesses
are
kind of few and far between right and so
there's for this whole community there's
one and it's a giant thing so
we're walking through the entire
community with our surfboards going
getting ready to go down the steps and
the way that this thing is organized is
it kind of it's a tree
of roads that go out into multiple
cul-de-sacs right
okay so we're having to like walk
through one of the cul-de-sacs
to like get on this path and there is a
woman she's also old
and she is walking
oh a retiree out for a morning walk
but we're walking down the road so i can
see her at the end of the cul-de-sac and
i'm like oh this woman has just reached
the end of the cul-de-sac and she's
looping around
but then i notice she loops in the
cul-de-sac again
and then i notice she loops in the
cul-de-sac again
she's looping in the cul-de-sac she's
her wall she's stuck
in the cul-de-sac i don't know if she
was stuck in a loop or if this was
intentional i believe it was intentional
and i'm like this is an interesting
choice because it's not like
leaving the cul-de-sac presents new
challenges you know what i'm saying it's
like it's still a flat road
it sounds like the senior citizen
version of a dog chasing its own tail
but she seemed happy but just like a dog
that's only one aspect of this woman
that i wanted to relay the second aspect
is the fact that she is listening to a
book
on tape is what i still call it gotta
walk man
uh uh and how did i know what she was
listening to because she was holding her
phone and it was on speaker
i've seen this before yeah now as you're
approaching
you're realizing this and you're also
realizing i'm not only gonna meet her
once
i'm gonna have to meet her twice well on
both sides of the culture no the timing
is
such that i could either completely
bypass her oh or
i could cross her at once but i'm not
going to get stuck in this this is a
strange practice
i mean i thought about getting stuck in
the loop just out of sympathy just once
just like come on boys we're going to
take a loop with this woman and then
we're going to release it but she's
listening to a book
on speaker not just any book why she's
listening to a romance novel
what because the only thing that i made
out was
she grabbed him by the hips
yes so she was listening to a romance
novel on
a loop on speaker and i
happen to get the sex scene which i mean
they're pretty frequent in a
in a romance novel probably three or
every three or four loops she probably
has a sex scene
it's a pretty big cul-de-sac it has to i
would say every three or four chapters
is a sexy uh it depends on i mean
i it depends it depends on who the
author is but
i was like this woman is living her best
life so did you get behind her when you
started to
hear the hips no i thought that would be
inappropriate but it
hit me i was like there are things about
this
scenario so weird that i could i could
worry about this woman like if this one
was my mother or my grandmother
i'd be like yeah grandma she's stuck in
a loop again and she's listening to a
romance novel on speaker
but then it i saw it in a different
light and i was like this woman has made
the choices
that she wants to make without regard
to anyone's opinion i mean i don't
she's not stupid she she didn't look
stupid
and she didn't care she didn't care
that i knew that she was in a loop she
didn't care that i knew that she was
listening to a romance novel
that the sex scenes were penetrating
okay
the air and my ears
and my children's ears
i admire this woman because i'm not
concerned about her at all
i just wanted to relay it as a beautiful
picture of humanity i just don't
i i i i is there a reason why she's
listening on speakerphone is it
that's the thing you're taking issue
with yeah that's that is the one thing
like
you're just bypassing the loop that
makes it yeah it's like uh
maybe you know i could come up i don't
really care about that you're right
but the but the it's just like the
people who talk on speakerphone like
this
i think it's tapping into a pet peeve of
mine people in public talking on a
speakerphone
when they should and they'll listen and
then they'll put the phone up to their
mouth as if it's not on speakerphone in
order to talk
people do this a lot like this is a
this is a version of that that's even
worse i think it might be a distaste
for headphones headphones like not
knowing how to use headphones or keep up
with them or she maybe she just lost
them
well i don't have headphones but i still
got to get my story yeah i think the
explanation of the loop she definitely
calls it my story is
is simpler than we might think i think
it could be
uh again nothing against people who are
aged
but it could be a bladder issue it could
be like i don't if i need to pee i don't
want to be too far away from my
apartment
right i don't want to be on the other
side of this complex when it hits me
maybe she just got back home
but she wants to hear more of her story
so it kind of like with a podcast you
might sit in your driveway to finish it
up before you go in the house
um but again that's this is why i the
other part is the part i care about yeah
maybe there's
i don't really care about our reasons
you don't care about ultimately that's
what i don't know that's your point
you don't care about the reasons but
that one the
using a speakerphone on a phone in
general
bothers me except in very narrow
situations
when you you're like you want your whole
family in the living room to hear what
grandma's saying on the phone call
sometimes i don't want to hold the phone
in my ear though i don't like doing that
either but i'll
i will go through the trouble to put in
the what if you don't have your
headphones the headphones
there are some times when i put it in my
ear man i'm doing it like a phone
well no there's sometimes like like nev
never in public
if i but if i'm in the house and jessie
calls me and she's
and she's talking to me and jessie does
this too i've noticed so i haven't
really thought about this until now
um like
my wife talks to her sister quite a bit
right and there are
many mornings where i go into the
bathroom
and jessie is like getting ready in the
bathroom and she's just got her
phone on the counter and she's having a
conversation with her sister like that's
very common and i feel like i i i i get
that you
you want it to be if you well here i
mean
i'm just saying at your house if you're
getting ready and you can't put stuff in
your ears and
because your face is getting wet
sometimes you just don't want to hold it
up here though when you're doing stuff
with both your hands yeah but ideally
there'd be a
i mean i do that i put the ear earbuds
in
but i yeah you're right i'm sure there's
a way to just celebrate it and say you
know what she's doing her thing
let's stay out of it yeah the woman in
the loop but you're right about the
cliffs to get back to that i mean
because we went to
um a little further south than you our
vacation was
uh del mar so we're like it um
like torrey pines nature reserve you got
there's the torrey pines golf course on
the on the south end of the fence and
then there's like this
this big point that comes out and it's
this reserve where these tory pines
reside i think it's one of the only
places on earth
where these particular pine trees grow
what makes them so tory
um what does that even mean i looked at
them and they i rode my bike up there
and uh
they didn't look that's i
i couldn't have said wow i've never seen
a pine tree like this before it was a
little bit different but it wasn't
they are the you have to be able to miss
the limbs start at the top now the
bottom are they
all the concentrate at the top um yeah
it's not tall and slender
it's more wide and even from a giant
christmas tree
uh but not rectangular either it's more
rectangular
you mean triangular that's what i meant
yeah triangular the old rectangle tree
so i was like
i'm interested in this it is a little
bit more like
unshapely going in all types of
directions
um than it being vertical and triangular
in nature
but you can also you have to time your
hike down on the beach in front of
torrey plungers or for the tides
i mean a lot of the beach here it just
goes away you get so excited about
renting a place at the beach and then
you get there and you realize
first of all i'm like 45 feet above the
beach
and i can't just walk out and just go
down like that's the
that's the north carolina beaches that
have spoiled us where it's like
a hundred yards of beach right uh before
you get to the water
and you have to time it right to to hike
that
the the frontage part like the beach
part of torrey pines reserve
and one of the main things you got to
watch out for is you can't walk too
close to the cliffs
because i mean and i read this thing in
their brochure
like a dude died like boulders fell
down like a little a little landslide
and just killed the guy
and it happens not infrequently
yeah i mean last time we went to the
beach closer to where you were
we set up our stuff on the beach and the
lifeguard came over and said you need to
get away from
you're too close to the cliff you've got
to be closer to the water
because uh it's dangerous and uh
i was told by somebody who lives down
there uh
so there's all these really nice homes
that are like right at the top of the
bluffs right and you see that some of
them have
like a a deck or something or a patio
that
literally it's beginning to erode
underneath
their patio yeah like there and i don't
know i may be speaking out of school i'm
just relying on testimony of one
individual who lives down there
but i was told that
if your property falls
into the ocean or falls off of the bluff
you cannot rebuild so it's very
difficult to get insurance
so if you're ha and everyone every few
years apparently somewhere along
california coast it's like oh there goes
my deck
somebody lost their house or a portion
of their house it become it
gets condemned and there's nothing you
do i was also told
that the steps that come down from the
homes to the beach which
a few homes have those if those go away
you can't rebuild those
hmm you you know the steps the um
up at point doom just north of malibu
this was our very first
ever uh uh paddle boarding excursion
which was a part of the mythical show we
had to walk down
all these flights of stairs with those
paddle boards in order to get down there
because it was more of an isolated beach
on the south side of westward beach and
that's where we tried to learn
because it was so isolated and um i took
christie there
for valentine's day we were going to
have like a
well we were just going to have a beach
date don't tell me the steps are gone
and it was so windy i was like i know
the place where we need to go
and we went to that place and
yeah they have removed all of the steps
i don't think they eroded away or
anything
they removed all of it you can't get to
point you can't get down there
and then there's like tape up like
caution tape
and there's a crane i think they're
gonna rebuild it all because there's a
crane there and it's been there for a
year though
and that's like a beautiful spot i was
like we're here
this is a beautiful spot it's
valentine's day there's no
there's so much wind this is the only
place that isn't going to have wind
and i go underneath the caution tape and
i'm like we're just going to go down
this
the steps and then i once we go under
there with our stuff
i'm like chrissy's behind me i'm like uh
there are no steps anymore but there are
people down on the beach so
if they can do it we can do it so then
for the next 20 minutes we're like
on our butts with like sliding like a
cooler
and a freaking blanket and
like you're just trying to get down the
cliff
you didn't end up having sex on the
beach did you because i know that you
guys like to do that uh i
you know how it is when like you have
these thoughts in your head and then
like when
when you're actually living the reality
you're thinking about it well i'm always
thinking about because i know you also
bring a blanket wherever you go
regardless of the season
well it's key to bring two blankets for
such a scenario as this
a really big blanket will work yeah one
that'll fold over yeah
i mean i've got i've got privacy
standards good gracious
but yeah none of that i mean it was
basically it was a near-death experience
to get down there
and then the whole time we're just kind
of worried how much is it going to be
more difficult yeah
i get so anxious about that kind of
thing like are we gonna like i'm always
like you know what i know i can do it
but i don't know if the rest of my
family can do it and i feel responsible
for them when we were coming down there
was this like
really buff huge guy and this really
small girl typical melody and then they
were
in a fight because he was down at the
bottom yelling at her
halfway to to just come on down
but not in a price is right kind of way
and i like i'm our
our relationship is is uh hinging on
this moment on this moment kind of a way
um as it should she did she did get down
there and then she did
you know she took off most of her
clothes and he started taking pictures
of her oh she's an instagram mod
apparently that's what happened did you
ask her for her
handle um hey i'm really interested in
what you've got going on here i really
like to see it on the internet
no but i mean christy talked to her and
encouraged her that she did a good job
of getting down the mountain
oh really i thought you were better but
i will say that christy passed her
and just showed her how it's done yeah
girl
we need to talk about not right now but
just
file this away the instagram
uh handles that are on the back of
trucks in north carolina
which is a health phenomenon i've heard
about this we got it we got to get into
that one day
yeah well i know we're going back home
and it's like maybe i think we'll have
fresh eyes coming back from going back
home and hopefully we'll see some of
that
you know what i'm i'm saying right now
when i go back home this summer
i'm gonna be on a mission to catalog all
the insta trucks that i see and then i'm
gonna have an insta truck
off on my instagram oh shoot well hold
on i want to join in on this
okay well it could be a tournament who
can who okay you you get your
hook it's the best who gets the best
insta
truck and it goes by who finds the one
with the most followers
wins the win wins a truck
oh okay all right so one of us is going
to buy the other guy in a truck
but it could be any truck it could be
like a 200 dollar truck that's okay
this is this is fun this is fun all
right
all right challenge accepted
let's sell some merch go to mythical.com
and pick up this
what does it say it says mythical is
happy yes mythicalness
mythical is happiness and the fact that
it takes that much
work to read it is what makes it good
part of the beauty of it
um i love how this thing fits it's like
a stone
wash um it's it's thinner so as it gets
warmer you still want to have that nice
hoodie
like you want it it's got a nice
spacious hood to it
and a spacious hood i don't like a
hoodie that's too thick
i mean at this time of year this is
perfect
for right now go to mythical.com also
check out our amazon store because we
got stuff that's only there amazon.com
mythical i'm switching out my mug
switching out your mug
put some water in it
all right so two weeks i mean um
i i think it was yeah episode before
last
in the video version we were we we cut
to footage
of jesse filming each of our kids when
we first moved to
los angeles when they were in the
airport 10 years we were talking about
the 10 year anniversary
and you know i know a lot of you got a
kick out of seeing that video
um i mean i'm just my heart just melts
at how little our kids were and we've
already talked about this
except to say that like lily was seven
she is she's and she was a
i guess she was about to turn eight
right right and now
she's she just turned 18. it's like
i i'm still trying to come to grips with
the fact that
like my daughter our first child
is an adult i it it's the first time in
a long time i've had this sensation that
i had
when chris and i got married because we
were the first ones in our friend group
to get married and
i was like wow i mean i know a lot of
people do this and it's
and i know that it's normal to feel
nervous but like in your immediate
finger to be the first one doing
something
that's such a statement was
it it added a little trepidation to it i
remember that feeling
because that's kind of what came back
when i'm like
man she i have an another adult in the
house
um but then the flip side of that is
i've done it like i am super proud of
lily and who she
is and who she's still becoming there's
a lot of a lot of work that she still
has to do
but it ain't my work anymore right
officially
you know i'm just like it hasn't been
for some time actually yeah
practically speaking that's that's abs
that's absolutely true
but it's you know there was just this
there's a card
there's like this trump card that you
can no longer play
when they're 18. at least it feels like
and it's like okay this is
really your decision i mean when she
turned 18
uh at the end of march i'm like
hey what you want
let's smoke some cigarettes join the
military
yeah make the most of this there's all
the stuff that you can do
and she's like uh i think i'll just
um you know uh
think about going to college and make
some progress
there and let's watch another episode of
survivor
you know that's the that's the thing i
mean she's been accepted
at one of her top choices but she has
she hasn't made a final decision because
she's on a couple of waiting lists for
colleges
uh for the fall um but that's exciting
we're gonna
but you know the the covet of it all has
changed so much about this and it's
yeah the fact that this is her that her
senior year was a was coveted
is it really kind of sucks for
unfortunately i think i think she's
she has made the best of it is how i see
it but
well we really came to appreciate how
much of an introvert she is
yeah that it's i mean she's not
she hasn't had a lot of frustration and
suffering from just
being in her own space there's in a lot
of ways
she actually thrived more so like her
quality of life
um is good has it has improved well it's
interesting i was i was reading an
article that was
that was about this very thing that was
the people who have secretly
thrived during kovid and are kind
and almost there's a there's a little
bit of shame about it because they're
like i know that this has been horrible
but
i kind of been into this and i think
it's an interesting contrast like
between
uh lillian locke because
lock is you know extroverted
but also just
you know super a challenger
and so he he just like i said in the uh
the video last week
um and just the idea that like he's
constantly complaining about the fact
that he feels like the
the history his junior year was stolen
from him yeah um
so i'm glad that it was his junior year
and not his senior year for his sake
just because the way that he is yeah and
lily doesn't
yeah she doesn't talk like that so that
that that's a good sign but it
you know it's i mean going off to
college especially with this transition
that she's making from
covid and then kind of getting back out
into normalcy and then being plunged
into this
world of college adulthood
uh which i feel like is different than
non-college adulthood i mean
you know that's just my
sense about it but it's there's a lot
there
in that transition and i think there
there has been this experience
of i'd and i i i'm this way
that like whenever i get stressed out or
intimidated by something instead of
diving into it and figuring it out fully
it's more like well if i can keep it at
arm's length i won't have to
um be as worried about it i mean it's
it's nice that she's been accepted at
like one of her
top schools that she wanted to go to so
like okay we know that the plan's in
place and everything's going but like
the details of like we're going to visit
the campus but we can't go
in the buildings yet and so it's just
kind of like seeing the campus on our
own there's no official
they'll send you like a virtual tour and
stuff like that
but it's she hasn't
really wanted to like explore everything
about it because
i think it would make it feel even more
real and it's something that
we kind of want to ease into because
over the course of kovid i mean she did
not really
she didn't have a senior year experience
so every all of these milestones that
you would have
that would really gear you up and
prepare you and excite you for
this next phase of life it's just
something that didn't happen
you know and i'm not right yeah you got
the you got graduation coming up which i
don't we
still don't know what that's going to
look like um you got the prom which
isn't probably isn't going to happen
you've got all the other things
throughout the year that seniors do that
make you feel like you're on the
precipice of the rest of your life
that i mean none of that happened for
for her birthday it just it takes a lot
of work to
be able to commemorate anything you know
she's got her friends
driving by in the front hanging out in
the front yard at a distance
and um you know she was surprised by
some of the people that
you know christy had contacted to show
up so she she was really honored and it
was really cool
but it's not nothing is tropish nothing
taps
into oh yeah this is this is how
people going into college this is how it
works on the cw network you know like
the
the tropish dramatic version and so now
you have this identification
with things through um just the typical
practices well one thing it's been real
strange
one thing for for for our kids
that i think helps with this a little
bit though compared to
think think about how predictable
our existence was at that time in our
lives right
we've been going we've been going to
school with the same people since first
grade
you since kindergarten and like
there was just i just think about what
covid would have been like
at harnett central high school in 1996
that senior year like if all of a sudden
we couldn't go to first of all like
how would they even have done they
couldn't have done online school because
no one had a computer at home
it's just like yeah but you just think
about how
we had these events one of the things
i've noticed just about
my kids is that those
tropish things that you're talking about
like prom and this is how you do things
and you go to the football game on
friday night like
i'm sure that's still happening in a lot
of places in america
but something about 2021
in in los angeles especially their
experience is just kind of different it
isn't
so i feel like they actually have more
capacity as much i know this is
contradictory what i was saying earlier
with a lot complaining about this stuff
but
i think and also the fact that they
moved in the middle of their
childhood to a new place and they were
homeschooled and then they started going
to school and
i just feel like our kids are a lot more
accessible so you got to remember is
going to going to high school as a
freshman
where right a student body of thousands
literally thousands of students i think
the fact that she
she's made that transition already
is like i think it's me
i think that her transition into college
my my take on it is that
it would it's going to be less less of a
deal for her than it would have been for
us if we had
if everything had been shaken up so big
she's excited about it she can't
i mean she can't wait for it she feels
like
she didn't she had a strange high school
experience so it's
you know she's she's get
she's excited about starting college on
like
more of equal footing with everybody
else which is in no way how her high
school career
uh started and then it fizzled out
before it really got going
and again i'm just grateful that she's
um
that she's been fine with it and that
she's she's found a way to
to to continue to be healthier
over the course of this past year
so you know when we when we went on a
spring break trip it was like okay
lily this is your last spring break trip
so
we wanted to do what we could within all
of the limitations that we have
so she brought a friend um
which was great uh great for her and you
know it's
you know it's uh it's
a friend of like her friend's family
we're all friends right so like we're
all hanging out
normally but so it's like we know her
really well
and so that that was nice for her to
have a friend there that like
lincoln was also friends with and that
but it brings a different dynamic to
vacation when you bring a uh
when a kid brings a friend i it makes
everybody's on a little better behavior
so i like that dynamic of it too
so she got a friend and we all got to be
a little more cordial
with each other over the course and the
kids behave
more yeah because they don't want you
know you don't want to
throw you no one wants to throw a
tantrum and embarrass you you don't want
to show your ass so
right when there's non-family there and
i'm not talking about lando throwing a
tantrum i'm kind of talking about me
but um yeah i'm just
having it having an a and and then just
so when it's whether it's spring break
or whatever it is just having this
mentality that like
and then i'll say this a lot to the kids
when they're at each other's throats
it's like you know well
lily you're not gonna you're not she's
not gonna be here much longer she's
gonna go off to college and then
you know somebody's gonna have to take
care of her cat
the cat the cat is gonna be how we like
feel like a connection to lily well
that's interesting like taking care
that's why i
doesn't feel that connection to you
that's how i'm trying to work that out
in my mind is that like
okay i can't me caring for the cat when
lily is gone
until we can get this cat to live with
the like which i assume can't happen
freshman year
well i'll sneak it in there um
but now everything is kind of shifted
that way in terms of like
this may be the this is there's only a
few more months before lily leaves so we
got to make the most of this let's not
let's not be jerks to each other kind of
thing how's that working now i
i can tell sometimes that it actually
works a little bit
like if i say something i mean
especially lando because lando
i mean you should have you should read
the card that he
like hand wrote a letter to lily for her
birthday and was talking about how much
he loved her and how
how much he hopes that her going off to
college will be a great experience and
you know it's super sweet
but even lincoln you can kind of see
it's like we all
are like coming to grips with the facts
like we've never
they've never lived life without her
in it so the wheels are turning
for them that like okay this is gonna be
this is not gonna be easy this this is
this is gonna be sad and i mean
i i i'm sure when we get
i'll share the whole experience when it
comes of like
taking the daughter to college and
leaving her but like man it's hard to
it's hard to think about even right now
because it's uh
it's it's there's so much emotion
wrapped up in this thing you know of
of her uh leaving home
and but but at this point it looks like
she's not going
real far like at one time she was like
looking at like the
university of hawaii and she got
accepted there
and we're like oh you don't i mean it's
hawaii's great i love to have an excuse
to go there more often but
i don't like the idea you being stuck in
the middle of an
ocean that far away so i don't think
that's happening i think we're like
far enough away that like this is my
prediction she'll end up far enough away
that i won't be able to
see her or her to come home every
weekend or
every month but if i need to get there i
can
within and she does she's not in less
than a day's drive
she's not the kind of person who's going
to
uh be like calling you with every
problem that she runs into
like that she doesn't strike me as that
kind of person yeah i'm thinking of ways
to like
you know to foster more of a text
connection
to like build some habits so that there
will be
like we'll be in the habit of talking on
a
on a semi on a daily basis or at least
every couple of days
so that's yeah because i think the
tendency will be
more like you and i when we went off to
college it's like well first of all i
went home every weekend to get my
laundry done and to see my
my girlfriend that ain't gonna happen
with her
so it's i but besides that it wasn't
like i was talking to my mom
constantly or processing my my
transition with my mom
right i don't recall doing that well my
goal is that she caught you
your mom called you but you didn't call
your mom
as much and it was kind of similar to me
i right i mean
in my mind i did i remember and we were
only an hour away from home
going to college and then seeing my mom
again on thanksgiving like that's
i know that's not true but that's how i
processed it and
that's how like with with my kids
like if they if like my kids go back to
sometimes they'll like fly to north
carolina like
alone to like spend time with with
family
and it'll be like
a week and neither me or nor jesse has
communicated with them
in any form it's just and i'm just and
that because because that's just their
person they're just they're like me in
that way
and so i have a feeling that there will
not be this
going to see but texting every couple of
days but it is
such a going to college is different
than visiting oh yeah right so it's like
you i think you're gonna want to have
more of that connection but
especially so i'm trying to be strategic
now and say
all right we got to develop some habits
because if i just spring it on her then
i'll be badgering her
her first month on campus and to be like
not used to it kind of a thing i was
thinking about that this morning
actually
so i mean
i think that that was certainly the
defining experience of
of my spring break i want to hear more
about yours and i do think that
as we gear up towards and as
she leaves to go off to college that uh
i'll be processing that so you'll be
hearing about it
but um let's go to more of the temporal
well i had a vacation i uh i met another
person
on as part that was part of this
community
okay uh i actually met a lot of old
folks who were very curious
about things um curious about the
surfboard
like i'm carrying the surfboard and i've
got like my paddle because i'm paddle
boarding
uh they're asking lots of questions
these people must have not have lived
there because they would have known they
were like what's the difference between
that and a regular surfboard
can i see the can i see it can i see the
bottom of it just like two couples just
like asking questions
it's good to be old and curious is your
response like mine which would be
i'm gonna answer this while in motion so
as to say
that i'm not gonna i'm not here to have
a conversation with you
no i've i'm friendlier than you so like
you'll like stop you'll like shift your
weight to your heels
make eye contact with a stranger and
then have a meaningful conversation
as i did that's vacation man good for
you um
but the more interesting thing my
problem is i'd be like i got to get in
that water
i'm on them i was coming
i got to get in the shower i'm on a
mission oh really
yeah well let me tell you i wonder how
you would have dealt with this so
we're getting ready to uh to go out and
i
had just purchased um insurance two new
boards
for the boys like two foam boards
because we had like one
anyway and i learned something that
uh there's this soft top wax
for surfboards like i always thought
like oh soft top
surfboards don't need any wax but the
guy at the place was like no
actually there's a thing called soft top
wax and it'll make the experience a lot
better but it's a different wax it's
softer
so we're like outside in the little sort
of common
[Music]
area where it's like this landscaping
and grass and stuff
and we've got the boards out there and
i'm making the boys like
wax their boards and uh this older dude
comes out of his
condo and he's got on a visor
perfect and um obviously
i wasn't allowed to the hairdo i respect
the visor thought about
wearing one from time to time but he
says um
hey where is he sorry and he just he
just he i
you know how when somebody begins
talking and you're like oh this is one
of those guys who just
likes to talk to people yeah me i can't
even remember what the first thing out
of his mouth was almost just like
i've never met you before but i'm
picking up where our last conversation
that we never had
left off it's like he's picking up where
the last conversation left off with
someone else yeah right it's just i'll
just keep going i'll keep going with
these guys
and then i said and so we're talking to
him for a little bit
and you know he's he's from he used to
live in a similar area in
in la that we live in and so he's like
talking about some like restaurants and
stuff and i'm like this guy
this guy is a aggressive talker now
as i said i'm friendly i'm not an
initiator of i don't initiate many
conversations with people but i respond
and engage
so you answered his questions but you
didn't ask questions
i didn't need to ask this man any
questions to get any information
but so but he's
he's kind of you can tell that he's sort
of like
sensing okay like okay here's a dad and
then there's a couple of boys
teenagers whatever and uh so
he goes he you can tell he's reaching
into the back pocket of his stories that
will impress teenage boys
ah he's like well um i was in college
oh uh i got a job with a
with a beer company delivering beer well
what kind of job is that for a college
guy
taking kegs around i'm like oh where is
this going
the boys are getting a kick out of it i
can tell they love it they love hearing
this kind of thing
he's like and then he decides to like
take it up a couple of notches and he's
like and then there's one morning
i gotta deliver to this uh strip club
and i go in there in the morning and
it's
it's the morning there's nobody in there
but there's a girl on stage shaking her
titties
oh god so i mean i didn't at that point
i was just like
how long is this going to go right
because it's like he's he's got he's
gone
he's like what's what's going to happen
i've said nothing i've not encouraged
anything and we've already got beer and
titties and
where else do we go from here right and
uh
so he keeps talking and he finishes that
story which
i mean none of the stories were good it
just they had buzz words in them you
know what i'm saying but
they didn't have nothing happened they
didn't have a beginning middle and end
okay
so he keeps going and at this point
we've
i can tell that now locke and shepard
are kind of they're nobody's in the
strip club
do they it's kind of like he's lying
if a stripper falls in the club and no
one's there do you hear it right
right he's lying because they don't just
go out there
you don't know neither one of us have
ever been to a strip club okay i haven't
been to a strip club but i'm saying i
know enough about
life and people to estimate
that if somebody comes in they're like
oh surely go out there on the stage
but if no one's out there on the stage
do you think shirley's just gonna be up
there but he was just delivering
he was the delivery guy yeah but maybe
maybe she could get some
some some some dollars he did he didn't
say he gave her anything
but at this point in this in the story
lock and shepard have both finished
waxing and now they're kind of waxing
for show
okay you know it's like okay well i
don't i'm gonna keep moving my hand but
i've fully waxed my board at this point
but he's just getting going oh and so
then
he realizes that's when i would have not
i would have stopped i would have put
this stuff away and i would have stood
he then notices that i'm not saying
anything back to him
i'm kind of fake laughing at certain
things yeah yeah
but then he's i guess he sensed that he
was like so what do you do
oh and i was like oh gosh oh gosh
i mean these are titties this is such a
loaded question for us as we've
discussed many times and as you
have you did at one point when an uber
driver
asked you what you did you answered i
make corporate videos
because you wanted thank you for
reminding me you wanted to be truthful
but to shut the conversation no one
wants to talk about those
corporate videos so i'd if the
corporation happens to be youtube and i
and and so google i don't
i can't do that uh but i got pretty
close i did what i usually do which is
um i i run a production company in la
that's what i that's what i say probably
a little too loaded
yeah because he immediately responded
with
i know this is the anecdote that he
responds to anyone that he finds out is
even tangentially involved with the
entertainment industry he says
do you know they made titanic and
tijuana
what so okay
and i'm like no he's like you didn't
know that like he's disappointed in me
mr i have a production company in los
angeles and i didn't know they made the
titanic
and tijuana a movie that was made in the
mid 90s
that i have nothing to do with because
i'm not in the movie industry but so
and i'm like really first of all he's
it you had to be relieved that like it's
immediately back on him
and you're learning something i don't
know if i'm learning truth though i mean
it doesn't matter it could be true
tijuana mexico and so then he tells me
the
the connection that he has with a guy
who worked on the movie and then he
tells me a story about them like
you know the scene where the water is
coming down the hallway
well first time they shot that they
didn't support the walls well enough
and it just went in the hallway and it
just knocked the walls down
and so he's proud of the fact that he
knows this and he's
and he's strangely like a little bit
irked that i didn't know this
how do you own a production company in
los angeles and you don't know these
classic titanic tijuana stories
quit now uh but eventually
when i didn't really respond much to
that because at this point i was kind of
losing my patience
he was like he didn't say anything
he just turned around and went inside
what yeah he was just like
and he was gone it was just like hold on
okay hold on did you see him turn and
walk away or was he just gone
because there might be an angel
situation happening no a titty angel i
saw him go in
i think he needed to get another beer i
think this dude yeah
this dude's still about beer and titties
at this point and there's i believe
there was a lot of beer
going on i think that's the name of a
ludicrous album beer diddy's
yeah um it isn't that but it's close to
him so
i can't believe he just walked away yeah
i think this is mo
i think he's just like all right i'm
done drop the mic go inside he doesn't
he again he started the conversation as
if we were picking up
somewhere where we left off with the
conversation we never had and he just
ended it
with no pleasantries okay like no have
fun out there or anything
just like do you want a wall steady's
beer and he just
turns around and he's in his house he
knew you got what you came for
right yeah he said i've been he's like
i've been through it all i told the beer
and titty story i've told the tijuana
story
what else do these guys need what do
they want from me
so we go inside and then shepherd clock
and [ __ ] he's like
should i have tipton loch and shepard
are like
that guy was awesome like they just
thought he was great
um and i was like well he's not really
great and he's not really awesome
but let me tell you the highlight of
of i've saved it for last nice i have a
highlight
of the the vacation uh
not a lot happened in a good way right i
mean it was
kind of just chilling in this condo yeah
that's what we did
uh lots of cereal eating some ice cream
eating
just taking it easy watching tv oh yeah
uh we did get deeply sucked into
another reality show as a family
uh shout out to 60 days in i know that
some of you are fans
but okay you need to stay focused
in the united states arizona i think
okay and he has created this
program where he gets normal
folk to go to jail and it's
it's technically jail it looks like a
prison situation like more
long term but it's technically jail it's
like holding people for their court
dates and stuff like that
and he you go in and you become a
prisoner
or an inmate or whatever the correct
word is
for 60 days and
you hit the the sheriff's idea is that
you're going in
as like a spy to like get information so
he can figure out like how drugs are
getting into the jail and stuff like
that and like all the
real jail it's real and it's in its
fifth season and the fifth season is on
netflix and the first four seasons i
think were on a
e it's mind-blowing that
this is a this is a show a real jail
with real inmates
and they film the whole thing but then
you put in someone who is guilty of
nothing in order to get information you
put like two or three women with the
women and two or three men with the men
and you follow them and you do
interviews with them and you do
interviews with other
inmates and the whole time it's being
filmed and they think everyone in the
prison thinks or in the jail thinks that
this is just a documentary because you
know they film documentaries in
these places all the time and
i'm not going to say that it's quality
television but so just because they're
incarcerated once you're wide to
there's a lot of ethical questions
raised just by the fact that this show
exists
but that didn't stop us from consuming
the entire season in one week
so anyway um
i did it was and the kids were just
especially shepherd was just like
really into it and just kind of we were
all kind of blown away that it was
hey that this show happens and it kind
of
that effect never wore off again not
quality television but just
but the highlight of the trip of course
was it was interacting with the ocean
right
and i'm sorry that wasn't a joke
interacting with the ocean so of course
you know i've got
big big dreams of having and i'm sure
that this is the way that you think
about it when you go down to
the beach for a week you're like i'm
going to surf i'm going to tear it up
i'm going to
own this i'm going to i'm gonna finally
ascend
to like looking like i know what i'm
doing status
talking turning a corner right yeah
never happens
of course so we go out there the first
time
my board never got off the top of my car
so no matter what you say i'm going to
be jealous
i did ride my bike a few times how did
that happen
combination of weather and then
logistics and
i can't i can't get anybody to go with
me in my family surprisingly the boys
are really into it
and i say that just because it's it's
not easy
and it's very when you don't have
anybody who's really instructing you
right so we go out there and um
it's a pretty big week waves wise
and it was one of those times i was like
good lord it was really hard to get out
past the breakers and
um the waves broke in different places
it wasn't like a predictable like this
is where they're breaking every time
it's like sometimes be like another 50
yards out it's breaking and so you're
like oh crap i'm too far
so me and lot go out there and we're
like getting beat up and then i look
back and like
shepherd who doesn't get out past the
breakers he like just tries to surf the
white water
he is really struggling and i just
i worry that his spirit is going to get
broken you know i don't i want to have a
good taste in his mouth
and then i kind of see that he's just
sort of sitting outside of the water and
sitting on the beach so i'm like i go
back in i haven't caught any waves i've
like totally wiped out a couple of times
just because the waves were
unpredictable and it just
i wasn't having a good time locke wasn't
having a good time
shepard had quit so i let go and i'm
like trying to help shepherd
by like taking him out there and pushing
him into the waves but the
the the undertow or the side toe was so
intense that i could barely stay with
him i was like
man did we pick a bad oh the the beach
was rocky
yeah and i'm like barefoot i didn't
bring my bring my booties and i was like
in the water like stepping on rocks and
like my feet hurt and
of course you're cold because you know
it's california it's not looking good
right
and so this is day one and i'm like oh
man is this
i knew this was gonna happen i knew that
the surfing wasn't gonna be good i
started seeing things like that like you
you've always got your expectations set
so high for how things are gonna go and
how things are gonna be and i you know i
brought my regular surfboard and you're
finally gonna be able to do regular
surfing and not just stand up paddle
boarding and
the boys are gonna get good at you know
none of that was happening
and so we kind of go inside a little bit
defeated
and then the next day rolls around and
there was a part of me that was just
like you know what maybe you shouldn't
force it
you shouldn't force it on yourself don't
force it on your kids
just just just vacate
is that how is that how you eat vacation
you vacate yeah definitely
just continue vacating and don't worry
about surfing if it happens it happens
so i'm kind of sitting up there in the
condo i can see
the ocean and i can see some uh
it's like mid-morning the next day and i
see some uh like i didn't get up and go
i see some guys on paddle boards which i
hadn't seen before and they're kind of
like
getting some waves and stuff and they
can i can tell that they're old
nice right and i'm kind of in that age
group but these guys are like
60s gray hairs i mean not that that
makes you
60s but these guys were old
and i mean even white hairs and they
are kind of killing it out there so i'm
like screw it i'm going
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna ask the
kids to go unless they want to go
so i go down the steps paddle out there
paddle i'm like paddling around these
old guys i'm like it is a little bit
calmer today like it wasn't so hard to
get out that's nice
and i'm like talking to one of the guys
catching anything he's like oh yeah
every couple of minutes something comes
along
huh i was like yeah i've been watching
you from my porch
and then i start noticing that
the dolphins are out the dolphins
and they're not just out
they're like putting on a show what what
do you mean
well hoops fire two and three dolphins
at a time like
are they're swimming in these little
pods and he the
one of the old guys was like yeah the
dolphins are really feeding today
they're like
you know because they're like literally
like swimming a couple of feet
away from you and then like going under
your board and then coming up on the
other side and stuff they know that
you're there right oh yeah
and they know that you're an another
intelligent being
and they know that you're into watching
cool things
[Laughter]
and so you think they're doing it for
you no i think they're doing it because
they're just
expressing themselves but they also know
that it's cool
i mean their brains are bigger than ours
yeah they'd be if they had
they'd be in charge if they had thumbs
and they'd have hands and that would
look
weird they wouldn't be nearly as agile
if they had thumbs i do realize that i
don't think they'd be cool
and they would know it then one of them
jumps completely out of the water i've
never seen
i've never seen this other than at sea
world which we don't go to anymore
because they don't they don't treat them
badly
completely out of the water total
dolphin body
two feet out of the water head to tail
complete
out of the water what 20 feet away
wow and i'm like oh yeah and then
did you have a tear no i was just like
i'm i
i said out loud to myself
always choose the experience that's you
know
i was just reminding myself this is it
man
i know it's hard you're not a great
surfer you're frustrated
you're kind of out of shape and you're
tall and you don't have great balance
but look you're out here and look what's
happening the dolphins
are putting on a free show then yeah
there's a a one dolphin that was a
little more weathered
than the other ones he looked older and
darker
and more worn okay
i noticed that every time he comes up
he's snorting
like through his blowhole his blowhole
is making a lot of noise
right and i don't know if he was doing
it to be cool
okay or if it's just a condition but i
appreciated it
it was like wow i mean this this guy's
making all this noise
you know none of the rest of them are
jumping and doing things but this guy
he's making a lot of noise
dad grunting yeah i appreciated that and
then
that's wild and then
a wave comes and i'm like
now i had tried to catch a couple of
waves and again put on a show for the
dolphins
again it's complicated do you know how
when you're out
i'm out pretty i'm out several hundred
yards you know i'm
way out in the ocean because
the way that the waves work at this
particular beach the beach break
is there's a waves of a certain size
break out there and then
they so they break and there's white
water and then they kind of stop and
then they reform early
you know further inside but you want to
be out there especially on a paddle
board because
you don't have to get through those
every time so you're actually kind of
surfing these waves
on a first break way out there and then
kind of like as they kind of
dissipate you go back out and you so
you surf and you never like you never
fall off your board you never have to
peel out of the way the way this kind of
dissipates but you get a good
like 10 12 second surf which is awesome
and then sometimes if the wave is big
enough it'll reconstitute while you're
still in it and you'll catch the second
break and take it all the way to the
shore right
that did happen one time in the during
the week
but anyway i catch a wave and like
i'm don't look like an idiot and i do it
right and i'm in the pocket and i'm like
going sideways
and i'm like yeah dolphins i'm catching
waves
and then as i'm paddling back out
there's another wave that's coming at me
and i look into the wave and there's two
dolphins
surfing in the wave what like in their
their
their their like noses are just piercing
out of the face of the wave and they're
like oh yeah and they go right under my
board
really yeah i mean and that's not as
cool as the time i was surfing
and there were dolphins on the wave with
me but i was just like
ah this is this is why i'm here
and then so that that the highlight of
my trip which you know the highlight of
my life is when i called away from the
dolphins were on the highlight of my
trip
was just out there having chosen the
experience
having a little bit of luck with surfing
but experiencing these dolphins
dang man i'm envious and then uh at that
point i come back and i tell my
doffing stories and that kind of gets
the boys kind of back into it
the rest of the week we went out once
often twice a day locks catching waves
shepard's catching the waves on the
inside
um and then the final day
uh i actually met so my therapist lives
close by to this area so i actually had
my therapy appointment
on the beach it was the most southern
california thing ever
walking with your therapist down the
beach but i love everything about it
and then um
it was like can't we have a uh
can't we make a why can't we surf during
a
a therapy session i mean who says we
can't do that
so we did okay and lot came out
and this was the sun that was literally
watching
the sunset while surfing like with the
saw the sun go over the horizon while
surfing
and then big wave came
me and like catch it together and i'm
like
party wave you always got to say party
wave when you put two people catch away
and like we're like boards are like two
feet apart and we're like
big wave flying on this wave
and i'm like he you know we're both uh
regular footage so he's in front of me
so he can't see me i'm like yelling at
him just so he understands that we're on
this way together he's like looking back
at me
and then like he totally wipes out right
in front of me but
not after we had surfed for a good 10
seconds i mean it was like we got we
caught this wave it was it was great
and then that was it that was the last i
was so tired by after that i didn't surf
the morning of the last day it was just
like
boy i'm out of shape but
i had some i had some special that's
amazing man special moments
i'm so mad that it was you and not me
[Laughter]
yeah i mean and also it just reminded me
is like we got it i mean we got to get
back out there
we got to get back out there regular
basis it's just
you know we're so far we're we're so far
i mean an hour from the people don't
realize how big los angeles is we're
like an hour from the beach
um so you kind of have to make plans for
it
but i do i love the principle of
like as often as possible
say yes to the experience i love that
i love that now it's your it's your week
for the wreck
oh so um uh so yes to the experience i
want to get your
get your wreck but you know one of the
things you talked about i think
i i can since we kind of planned out
what we're going to talk about for the
next ear biscuit we can give a teaser
you know you were talking we were
talking about lily at the top and
talking about
the mentality of coming out of covid and
like
the things you find yourself thinking
depending on your personality type
um i think has led to
some some some interesting instincts
that go against what i thought i would
be feeling at this point
what i'm talking about is joining a
commune
as and we've started to talk about this
right so we
then we've saved it for for next week
we'll talk about
um are we are we going to move from
quarantine to
commune life because there are some
legitimate
opportunities that we could
that we could do this i'm into it
so we'll talk about that next week but
give us the risk okay my wreck
is television related but it's quality
television i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna recommend 60 days in uh
i'm gonna recommend
uh this is typically typical dad this is
what i do i recommend
shows that have been out for a while but
you may have not
watched them uh rami on hulu
which so many people had told me to
watch
and um i just you know there's a lot of
stuff to watch
but i started watching it just before
spring break
so it's a you know half hour comedy
featuring an
egyptian-american guy who
uh a muslim egyptian-american guy who's
kind of
trying to balance his life as someone
who
has like a religious commitment but is
also
fully american and it's hilarious
it's it's got a lot of heart
and uh first of all you know i
i don't have that you know i i don't
have the egyptian american
muslim experience personally
but i understand what it's like to grow
up in a very
religiously uh intense environment
uh and culture and and also to kind of
come to a place that sees that
differently you know like in
moving from the east coast to the west
coast from north carolina california
anyway highly recommend it
one of my favorite shows
i mean right definitely right now and
they're still making it i think
and it's recently won you know several
awards and i think the third season is
coming out at some point but
anyway rami on hulu
i recommend it hashtag gear biscuits let
us know
what you think how you responding and
processing these conversations
we enjoy reading those and uh
we'll talk at you next week to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best